[Musique]
mais elle est très fatiguée
elle s'endort
si le français de ces jeunes femmes est
encore hésitant c'est qu'elles sont
arrivées d'afghanistan il y a quelques
mois à peine elles ont quitté kaboul en
catastrophe alors que les talibans
prenaient une nouvelle fois les rênes du
pays
aujourd'hui réfugié en france elles
savourent leur liberté mais pense aux
proches qu'elles ont laissé derrière
elles
dans ma propre famille ma soeur ne peut
plus aller à l'école
elles restent enfermés à la maison en
permanence
je suis inquiète pour elle pour mes amis
et pour toutes les filles en afghanistan
depuis que nous sommes arrivés
je pense sans arrêt à ceux qui sont
toujours en afghanistan à ma famille
bien sûr on se sent mieux ici loin de la
guerre mais j'ai vraiment peur pour eux
contrairement aux apparences c'est
afghanes ne sont pas à l'école mais au
théâtre le tnp de villeurbanne leur
dispense des cours de langue mais il
offre aussi une résidence artistique à
ses neuf comédienne et leur metteur en
scène lane ce dernier a fondé cette
troupe 100% féminine à kaboul en 2015
à ses côtés le directeur du théâtre
accompagne les jeunes femmes lors de
fréquences ateliers tous deux espèrent
les voir jouer sur scène bientôt
[Musique]
on rêve de leur donner de la place de
leur donner la parole de leur donner la
liberté de raconter c'est pas du tout
l'enseignement de la tradition théâtrale
française pour une troupe afghane qui
arriveraient pas du tout c'est
comprendre d'abord qui est ce qu'ils
sont ce qu'ils veulent avant de avant
d'imaginer plus concrètement un
spectacle qu'on a envie de faire bien
entendu en créant ses troupes notre
principal objectif était de soutenir et
de développer la participation des
femmes au sein de la société
nous voulions aussi que leurs familles
accordent leur confiance à ses filles
pour qu'elles puissent mettre à profit
leurs talents et en faire profiter les
gens à travers leurs activités
artistiques avec les talibans au pouvoir
qui ça serait impossible en afghanistan
le tnp le centre dramatique national de
lyon se sont associés pour accueillir la
troupe mêmes leur fournir un logement de
nombreuses institutions culturelles ont
pris des initiatives similaires en
france
âgés de 18 à 23 ans à peine ces
comédiennes veulent faire de leur
expérience un symbole
on afghanistan des millions de femmes
sont réduites au silence elles n'ont
plus le droit à la parole nous sommes
venus ici pour porter leur voix à
travers notre art et prouver au monde
que nous pouvons nous exprimer librement
et rester en vie
près de trois mille afghans ont été
évacués par avion est accueillie
officiellement en france depuis août
2000 21
parmi eux d'anciens interprètes qui ont
travaillé avec les troupes françaises
stationnées en afghanistan
comme ali qui habite aujourd'hui avec sa
famille dans une petite ville de savoie
j'ai travaillé avec l'armée française
20 12 2009 jusqu'à 12 juin 2013 à kaboul
donc c'était un gros problème pour nous
pour ma famille pour mes enfants qui
l'ont aller à l'école
des gens ils ont appelé désespérante
étaient des chrétiens
ali est même victime d'une attaque au
couteau en 2020 il craint le pire quand
les talibans prennent le pouvoir mais
l'ambassade de france à kaboul l'aide à
fuir avec sa famille
l'afghanistan est maintenant dans les
mains des talibans et malheureusement
ils nous respectent rien je me sens
calme ici on sécurité et après j'essaye
de trouver la solution pour
mes enfants
objectif permettre à tous d'étudier en
france
ces petits jumeaux viennent d'entrer à
l'école primaire locale quatre de ses
six enfants sont déjà scolarisés
mais les afghans arrivé clandestinement
en france depuis la victoire des
talibans ne bénéficie d'aucun traitement
de faveur
illustration dans ce campement illégal
tout près de paris autour du feu la
plupart des hommes ont fui leur pays
récemment comme nous l'expliquent reza
jafari dont l'association vient en aide
aux migrants afghans
je me bats on se bat beaucoup
d'associations se bat pour un accueil
dean en france les moyens existent la
plupart de ces gens là sont en quitté
l'afghanistan après le 15 août et il va
y avoir un flux migratoires très très
fort
pourquoi le gouvernement de ce grand
pays ne nous est il pas soit ils
décident de fermer complètement leurs
frontières soit il accepte de s'occuper
de nous et s'ils le font ils doivent le
faire correctement c'était bien plus
facile pour les réfugiés arrivés par
avion ils n'ont pas eu à payer quoi que
ce soit
d'après les dernières estimations près
de cent mille afghans vivent aujourd'hui
dans l'hexagone à leur arrivée beaucoup
finissent à la rue après un périple de
plusieurs mois et entame un parcours du
combattant pour obtenir le statut de
réfugié depuis 2018 les afghans forment
la plus importante communauté de
demandeurs d'asile en france